[Musique]
avec vous bilal tarabet ce matin bonjour
bilal bonjour pauline avant de parler de
l'ukraine d'abord quelques mots de la
vague de chaleur qui progresse dans
l'hémisphère nord et notamment ici en
france est à la une de nombreux
quotidiens ce matin oui oui cette vague
de chaleur qui progresse en france et
est à la une de nombreux quotidiens dont
le monde le quotidien du soir avec
d'abord cette question qu'est ce qu'une
vague de chaleur puisque après tout
n'importe qui peut dire qu'il fait chaud
or ce sont des valeurs qui sont mesurées
vous allez le voir précisément météo
france définit une vague de chaleur donc
évidemment ça dépend des pays et des
climats une vague de chaleur n'est pas
la même en france qu'en norvège qu'en
suède ou qu'en mauritanie on s'en doute
bien alors il y a en france qu'on
appelle l'indicateur thermique nationale
ça c'est une température qui est mesuré
tous les jours depuis 40 ans par trente
stations thermiques qui sont répartis
sur tout le territoire français donc en
fait une vague de chaleur c'est quand
les températures restent au moins trois
jours consécutifs au dessus de cette
moyenne normal donc en l'occurrence en
ce moment trois jours consécutifs au
dessus de 23,4 degrés c'est précis et
lorsque pendant ces trois jours la
température atteint au moins un pic en
l'occurrence en ce moment 25 4 degrés
alors pour information donc vague de
chaleur on parle pas simplement d'aller
faire trempette dans une fontaine les
vagues de chaleur elle tue il faut le
savoir la pire vague de chaleur en
france reste celle de 2003 de d'août
2003 qui avait fait non seulement 15000
morts en france mais soixante dix mille
morts en europe le réchauffement
climatique est là la question bilal ce
n'est plus est ce que la france se
réchauffera mais quand oui et pour le
figaro cet horizon
c2050 le figaro nous propose un long
article on le voit ici aux allures de
roman d'anticipation qui démarre ainsi 1
malgré le bourdonnement incessant de la
ville nombreux parisiens ont ouvert en
grand les fenêtres de leur logement il
est 4h30 du matin il fait déjà 24 degrés
nous sommes à paris ce dimanche 30
octobre
2050 alors au delà de la poésie cet
article se base carte à l'appui et
photomontages en le voit alors pas par
exemple cette photo c'est une maison
typiquement normande donc la normandie
pour ceux qui savent pas où c'est c'est
au nord-ouest de la france donc c'est
quand même pas une région qui est connu
pour sa chaleur méditerranéenne et on la
voit ici dans un paysage typiquement
toscan italien et pour le quotidien des
c'est à ça que ressemble leur à la
france en 2050 la neige pourraient avoir
disparu de quasiment toutes les alpes où
les grands champs de blé du centre de la
france seront remplacés par des petites
exploitations de légumes ou de céréales
et où accrochez vous bien les moustiques
tigres porteurs de la dengue ou du
chikungunya
pourraient circuler dans le pays y
compris au nord de la loire une dystopie
donc il n'y a pas qu'en france bilal que
cette vague de chaleur inquiète le
réchauffement climatique est évidemment
un phénomène mondial oui et figurez vous
que pendant qu'on parle de cette vague
de chaleur en france et bien aux états
unis plus de 100 millions d'américains
sont appelés à rester chez eux c'est
plus d'un tiers de la population
américaine nous rappelle le guardian
britannique
là bas aussi une vague de chaleur
exceptionnelle un frappe le pays en ce
moment je vous donne quelques exemples
43 degrés à las vegas 38° à denver 43
degrés à phoenix et même 38 degrés à
chicago où trois femmes sont décédées à
cause de la chaleur dans leur
appartement le quotidien britannique le
guardian bilal qui est revient
évidemment largement également sur la
visite inédite des dirigeants français
italien et allemand à kiev ils sont
attendus ce matin à kiev c'est désormais
un conte quasiment confirmée c'est ça
on l'a largement commentée vous l'avez
largement commenté dans cette édition et
précédemment l'absence nous rappelle le
guardian de ces trois dirigeants à kiev
avait été critiquée donc non seulement
par l'ukraine qui les appelaient à venir
montrer leur soutien depuis le début de
l'invasion mais aussi au sein de l'union
européenne par les pays d'europe de
l'est notamment la pologne la lituanie
les pays baltes qui ont une ligne envers
moscou qui est beaucoup plus dur ou en
tout cas perçus comme tels que la france
l'italie et on le voit l'allemagne donc
cette visite a pour but de rassurer bien
sûr de resserrer les rangs au niveau
européen mais aussi de rassurer les
ukrainiens et le guardian où nous
rappelle ce qu'a dit hier emmanuel
macron en roumanie je pense que nous
sommes donc c'est emmanuel macron qui
parle je pense que nous sommes à un
moment où nous avons besoin d'envoyer
des signaux politiques claires nous
union européenne à l'égard de l'ukraine
et donc on peut ajouter à ça la photo
diffusée ce matin par cette nuit plutôt
par nos confrères italiens de la
repubblica où ces trois dirigeants sont
dans le wagon du train qui les emmène à
kiev autre titre à la une en france les
élections législatives le second tour
c'est dimanche oui tout à fait alors
dépendamment du bord politique vous
allez le voir la couverture n'est pas la
même alors là ici on à libération qui
donc on le rappelle un quotidien
politiquement de gauche pour qui l'enjeu
c'est le vote des jeunes et qu'ils
appellent la nu pas continuer à se
concentrer je vais en substance il ya 4
pts 6 pages sur le sujet mais qui
appelle la nuque donc la coalition de
gauche a proposé un vrai projet de
changement pour les jeunes pour les
motiver à pour voter au second tour ce
qui nous amène au mois du jour tout à
fait cher pauline le mot du jour c'est
mélenchonisation comme dans la phrase la
mélenchonisation c'est assez dur a dit
renée esprit et ça c'est le figaro qui
inventent ce concept le figaro dont on
rappelle qu'il est politiquement de
droite alors la mélenchonisation des
esprits selon le journal c'est le miroir
de la lepénisation des esprits en son
temps en clair selon le journal la nuque
serait une coalition d'extrême gauche et
donc je vais le site et il suffit de
reprendre une à une les déclarations du
lit maximo hexagonal donc ça selon le
figaro c'est jean luc mélenchon et celle
de ses camarades
gauchistes mot kyste indigéniste et
cetera communautariste anti flics tout
ça ce pourrait être des mots du jour
pour lever les doutes sur la question
face à leurs diatribes la mansuétude des
médias c'est à dire nous peut-être et de
leurs adversaires politiques laissent
pantois donc voilà pauline selon le
figaro nous vivons une mélenchonisation
des esprits que vous avez dit trois fois
parfaitement merci beaucoup bilal